hey we we just had some questions about
your your last relationship he said he
was a narcissist yeah when did he become
a narcissist or you just didn't see did
he like win the lottery then became an
[ __ ] i'm sure the last thing you want
is a bunch of men screaming at you about
your failed relationship
it reminds me of tijuana
yeah like you know like tijuana like
revolution okay well i do
and um that it gets crazy yeah it's it's
it's a little unruly and awesome talking
about austin
did you like it
it was cool but i didn't it was like a
culture shock because um i uh
had never i i didn't know what to expect
it was like tattoo shops comedy clubs 24
7 convenience store mini is crazy it's
very it's very blue horseshit it is very
blue it's very blue yeah yeah and uh
welcome to the show by the way
yeah it's jessie mae
oh we started yeah
oh we're on um
real sneaky
jessie everybody yeah hey what's up and
stevie can you just lean back a little
bit your head is there's the camera yeah
that's a great dare shirt though stevie
did you get that is that i went shopping
the day before on melrose so i went to
urban outfitters i went to i got um i
got some these are i like those yeah
yeah i like your original kicks though
those are cool i like yours
the
lightning the lightning those are fire
i feel like steve's like got like like
he has like a little bit of cash now in
that savings account
and he's going he's on melrose
yeah why'd you go to urbana
you know he was like you go to urban
outfitters that's a very urban outfitter
shirt yeah a deer shirt i was wondering
i don't normally go there will you back
me up with you is how it would be on my
side
right past marshalls
they're getting it up on me i sound like
it does look like an urban outfitters
dare shirt it is so it doesn't look like
a vintage it looks expensive vintage
like a new
and then i you know put it out in the
sun or something
that's why you spent 50 dollars to make
it look like that how did you know it's
around that price because i know it has
straight holes in the side it's got fake
holes you have a 50 t-shirt on steve
there's 32 dollars who are you are you
are you bobby oh no these were cheap
these were like 60
this was like 32
that's all i got was did you feel like a
rock star at moon tower no i just stayed
in my hotel room i didn't know that see
the the problem is i didn't know how a
festival worked it's a party for comics
and for comics but there's always stuff
going on like itinerary like this time
you go here this time this is when david
tell goes you know jeremiah didn't help
he's been to him before he didn't he was
on so many shows like he did everything
he was hosting he was doing at the last
show the outro show he was on stage in
the rock and roll outfit like yeah it
was crazy yeah i was just in my hotel
room watching did you guys
you were also at the gas station you
said yeah well i went to bucky's yeah oh
yeah yeah
yeah so the highlights were beef jerky
oh well um
okay i tried i got this hot sweet tea at
the convenience store i really liked it
i put in my mini fridge sounds like a
success yeah you're traveling you're
just i'm i'm an amateur i didn't know
what to do i did the wrong thing mr
might not help him out i feel like you
could have just zoomed into this yeah i
don't know if you needed to go to austin
yeah
i i had fun at the live event all right
good yeah good turnout yeah we sold out
that room oh it's great man but i'm
trying to because y'all are comics right
i'm still trying to figure out the
format of
do i acknowledge them you know because
podcasting in general you don't have a
crowd but this time like it's just
i was aware how did you guys do it
stevie was it you and jeremiah with two
mics on stage yeah and we had a keyboard
we had a crazy challenge it was like a
performance though huh it's like almost
like a performance more so than a
podcast it's like a live it's like
stevie and jeremiah live exactly that's
what you want yeah nobody wants to see
you and jeremiah sit down at a table
like this and just talk to you no no we
had that format where his chair and then
we had these kinds of mike yeah so it
was like a podcast podcast it looked
wild though it did it did you see that
did you were you done on instagram
what's that were you at moon tower no i
wasn't no
i i stayed back i was supposed to be in
edmonton but i wasn't feeling good i
wasn't feeling good enough to travel so
i just stayed low for a week yeah like
how do they pick you y'all
know about festivals like how do they so
many comics how do they choose blood
samples
it's very simple dna do you submit a
thing like
eric have you been there i've never been
to moon tower actually really yeah i've
never been to that one who tower is cool
then just for laughs the big one yeah i
mean i've done just for last i've been
to the uh what's the what's the big one
in austin the real one the
real one
they always have comedy and stuff there
yeah but that's not like that's at the
forefront yeah that's the movies and
music yeah music and movies
like just
i guess i did go for a tv show so i get
i get it moon tower is more fun for i
feel like i feel like it's like the most
fun comedy festival besides i've never
been to that one in these countries they
always pass me by the the comedy
festivals are ancient the comedy
festivals are interesting though because
it's like i don't even know if you need
to do them i think if you're starting
out or unless you're a huge headliner
like bur or someone it doesn't make a
ton of sense why not
because just financially doesn't make a
ton of sense because i could fly even
austin and do my own show and make
probably double the money than what the
the moon tower would pay you because
it's a funny thing you don't go for me
so like when you were in austin doing uh
moon tower yeah i was literally an hour
away doing a theater in san antonio
that's him just humble bro
that was him just rubbing his dick in
your face a little his nut sack yeah
most of the comments okay
i got something to rub in your face
later in my i have something in my hand
in my back i have something in my bag
you just got verbally dick slapped
no no i'm just saying that you i mean
they're they're fun but the the boys
taking the lion share the gals and boys
making the lion share of the money are
the real big boys and then the rest of
it is just like
i have a huge weight on my shoulders i
didn't mean to cut you off buzz buzz
gang gang kids in a tiny apartment in
southern california two college dropouts
teamed up to create a watch company
called movement they broke all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors clean
original styles we all love them man
it's movement they grew into one of the
fastest growing watch brands shipping to
over 160 countries across the globe
proud of your boys now movement has
expanded to blue light glasses that
protect your eyes from screens all right
uh
everyone's staring at the screen so you
probably need these things all the all
these uh designs are out of the
california headquarters right you know a
lot of watch you see out there are
thousands of dollars but you see a
gentleman or gal watching a movement
watch and you're like what how much is
that that's probably the quality of a
four to five hundred dollar watch yeah
not with the movement man they cost a
fraction of that that's because they
were built online and they own their
process from start to finish you get a
beautiful watch ship right to your door
for free if you don't love it you can
ship it right back for free if you want
to elevate your look with style that
doesn't break the bank then movement is
for you get 50 off today with free
shipping free returns by going to mvmt
cats again that's mvmt.com
cats
yo man there's a lot of anxiety in the
world right now the world is crazy maybe
there's something interfering with your
happiness that's preventing you from
achieving the goals that you set for
yourself man whatever it is
my friends at betterhelp can help you
out man by matching with your own
license professional therapist
professional not your friend around the
water cooler not when your co-workers
none of that stuff man you can start
communicating under 48 hours not a price
line not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online man
service is available worldwide wide wide
wide log on anytime you want send a
message to your counselor you get a
timely thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly or video phone sessions
all right uh better help is committed to
making therapy great man so they got you
guys covered better help once you start
living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com kats that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact
you need to get on it man this podcast
sponsored by betterhelp and the king and
the sting listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com cats you
brought a special guest yeah but this is
there's a huge weight on my
shoulders there's something alive in
there yeah hey speaking of dna well he's
probably alive how much comes yeah
speaking of dna
you don't have to back up like that but
um
we were planning this for months and i
wanted to grow as a person i feel like
he does this on purpose because
you know perverted uh sexual matters
you're growing up dude you're moving
power i had this thing and
i'm gonna part with it today and we
announced it okay we're gonna part with
it i'm scared because he's filming why
are you filming me okay so this is uh
okay
oh
wow it's smaller than i thought so i'm
gonna just
just but the thing is
child's ass yeah is that like a
ten-year-old kid
is that
small black child
this is not child this is not child this
is an adult stop shooting that's not an
adult i'm gonna i'm gonna kiss you on
the butthole oh wow and then you guys
can you kiss each
other no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no
uh
how do you know how do you know i used
it yeah i guess oh we know you guys
because it's worn out like how do you
know steven do you know the class was
like
something he's got a good weight there
you go huh
i like what you're doing
that's what i did
so dude it's so tiny that's so little
you might as well have the whole body
can we do it can we do a little prayer
why didn't you just have the whole body
steve this don't even make any sense
that's how i came here i want to do a
prayer i just picked i just picked your
stevie at home like you say something
[ __ ] why he said something like he's
talking [ __ ] to it called warm out
dude this is a child's ass baby that's
the way it came in the box man that's an
adult
there's nobody
it felt
well it felt fantastic good man you
squeeze some vaseline and lotion in
there are you being like facetious or if
you're really [ __ ] no
this is just
i used to use the ride this has been
this has been his ride or died for like
six years wow how long have you had it
stevie let's just do the funeral
and can you stop slapping it down
i'm sorry no disrespecting you
no no no
no no
don't you [ __ ] after
okay we're gonna do it we're gonna do a
priority touch or just stop a moment of
silence
10 seconds
10 seconds
that's crazy i'm so concerned because
it's a child to us
you know what's crazy he's well then we
have to start over there i know that
science hold on a second steve steve's
beat this thing up so much it looks like
brendan's ear
[Applause]
that might get us kicked off youtube
nick
oh my god
oh geez
wow
[Music]
this one goes out to all the asses out
there
all the silicone that has been
abused
[Music]
and thoroughly loved
too thoroughly
that thing's gotten stevie through some
dark times
yeah the darkest times yeah oh wow
i don't like the bag you brought it in
i'm not touching that i'm not talking
steve i have a question steve steve
questions
it's so smart
thanks for doing that i'm disappointed
in the size was that growth that was
growth
i don't know what that was if you loved
it so much why'd you bring it in like a
plastic bag
that was gross well you started taking
my side because
those are the things because these guys
they gang up on me i need you on my side
[Applause]
penis is that big wow
do you think that was created out of
loneliness or someone's attempt to not
get cheated on
would you say that again that oh like
the the actual ass the [ __ ] butt do you
think it was guys can't get chicks i'd
assume
time stamp
because i know you're referring to me
because i'm the one with the butt
your situation's different your
situation is different i do have a
question steve just think about it
about it think about it i have my
question is
did you get
that color but because maybe it was the
cheapest or the only one they had or did
you actively be like you know what i
don't want to try the the black butt or
yeah it was it like why didn't you get
like a back me up on it
i'm genuine
was it a discount on my side
no you had you took that into your
trailer man you know someone took it it
disappeared
about it um it was given to me as a gift
i had no choice what friend gave you as
a gift
uh my friend david cho
oh he's got a lot of money he could have
sprung for the yeah bigger what do you
mean i know what that's the top of the
line pick the little one it wasn't that
long that one's top-of-the-line shrunk
but i'm a little guy stevie was he also
like hey man i know you're going through
a tough time here yeah
i don't know what kind of friendship
involves giving [ __ ] butts
that's that's pure friendship right
there what are you talking about maybe i
shot that guy are you saying it's
enabling wait a minute if you look at a
really good vibrator i have a couple
good ones okay you wouldn't you wouldn't
gift that to a friend of yours i i was
just going to say my girlfriend
yamaneika saunders when my dad died and
sent me a viper see oh wow it's the same
thing
why are you judging me oh because i i'm
in this podcast it's fun and i'm joining
in
you do use dildos and vibrators yeah but
then why are you not shaming me that i
have a black butt that's not different
it's a little different it's not
different it's the same it's the same
you know it's half a bottle it's not
different i'm actually with steve on
there thank you finally for once you
know why because the hypocrisy
like i'm sure her side table is like you
know a freaking best buy of you know
what i mean i wish now i need to go
shopping it's like a sharper image yeah
like you know they got all this
machinery and steve's got one silicone
black button and now we can shame him
for that you know
you guys did yeah we did you did this to
him we're shaming him on the size
[Applause]
do this and then you tell me when to
stop your fingers are so small we can't
trust steve has bad depth
guacamole
for real
i swear to god
that can't
you might as well just say hey you have
a micro penis
no absolutely not
stevie since you've come on the show
though there's been some growth for you
you've got moon tower you've gone
shopping with your outfit now thank you
you got rid of this black ass thank you
you beat up going you beat up a a kid
who lost 200 i didn't want to fight i
didn't want to wrestle that kid i liked
it i liked you i've been
i'll show you this so this george kid
shout out to george george okay he was
he was 450 pounds and uh a year and a
half ago he goes hey my goal is to lose
200 pounds and i want to wrestle stevie
because stevie wrestled so
nick surprised all this he lost 250
pounds he flies out here he surprised
everybody watson in a singlet so then
after the show him and stevie russell
you forget stevie was like goddamn world
champion california wrestler i was
reading the [ __ ] on this kid in the
states
takes them down like this
and then but george is such a good kid
he's so nice so i mean i didn't want to
hurt the kid i mean the thing is i felt
when i felt his when we locked up yeah i
felt like his the power of the weight
and i'm like it felt like thor's yeah
yeah and i felt him clubbed my neck and
i keto grizzly bear and what you didn't
see i tried to do a move call a duck
under no but his arm was so big yeah so
i tried to do that that was like that
was one of my go-to's in high school but
his yeah the yeah his arm was blocking
it so i'm like okay
i need to end this now or i need to at
least try to shoot in
so i did the sweep single yeah speaking
of just sticking down like that but so
then this kid i'm 130 something this kid
george uh great kid right just comes
from nothing works his ass off so he's
never like been on a plane he's never
stayed at a nice hotel so i flew into my
san antonio show and i put them in to me
it's the best hotel in america good for
you man
it's a hotel emma in san antonio it's my
favorite hotel in the world so i got him
the master suite at emma yeah because
never stay at a hotel play that video
nick
he's such a character too good kid
oh it's a beautiful hotel
wow
five star you know they got free music
on youtube you can use
this is a great thing that's him later
that's him now wow he was four and fifty
percent for him this is why i say you
gotta meet people when they meet a lot
of people
this kid don't give a [ __ ] yeah he's
such a personality too such a good kid
like a bag of milk still he's super
self-deprecative bag of milk
oh wow a lot of work to drop that much
weight though yeah man yeah he's just
doing it and he is hardcore cheating oh
he's adorable
that looked like the black butt wink
[Laughter]
they will not be at coachella this year
fans at the show were giving them love
man oh yeah he's never done anything
like this
he must have had so much fun oh my god
what kind of venue are you doing thank
you so much for coming out man i love
you guys
before i close out tonight you didn't
know how to bring this gentleman on
stage his name's george george
was 450 pounds and he said dude if i
lose 200 pounds i'll fly to la and i
will wrestle stevie i went dude you lose
200 [ __ ] pounds
i will fly you to la i will fly you to
my show have you backstage and where
george comes from he doesn't see stuff
like this so the point of all this
george is there's so much more to this
world man you can [ __ ] do it brother
i love you man keep it up san antonio i
love you guys
i was hoping i could see you take him
down
thanks george weight loss commercial i
just watched wow
i was hoping so you take them down i
like george a lot yeah
how did he lose all that weight was it
just good old exercise diet keto and
then he got the the tummy surgery uh
where they cut your gastric bypass he
did that yep wow yeah he looks young too
where is he from uh our uh south of
chicago
wow so uh both brothers od on heroin
father is in a basically a wheelchair
because so much drug use mom works like
18 hours a day
his sister who's currently an addict uh
had kids he takes care of the kid so
he's just like the best [ __ ] kid man
can we start a gofundme or something for
this guy
together the fact that he like took
initiative to like get his [ __ ] in order
and he's just a real sweet personality
he's such a good person yeah that's a
really good
like story about what it takes to make
change like you are capable of changing
what your story could become but also
think about the chaos that he's in like
me and him went to dinner after the show
and said you have to show up man she
wants to see it but well i want to hear
what you're going to do yeah well so we
went to dinner on saturday because i i
was about to do this charity thing
before the show so i didn't get a ton of
time with them then brought him
backstage and you're getting ready for a
show so i can't talk to him a ton then
after we went to dinner and he stuck to
his keto diet there was chips and salsa
from chicken wings he didn't touch it he
had a spinach salad with chicken like he
was terrible awful that's what i thought
that's why i said god that looks
terrible though but um but he'll get
into a groove
but he was telling me about like his
whole family and his sister and his
brothers and all and i'm like tearing up
and chappelle's next time you know
chappelle's been through some [ __ ] man
chappelle grew up a rough lifestyle so
chappelle's list to it and i was just
like dude you were dealt these cards man
and
it sucks you were dealt these cards you
can fold and go down the road that your
brothers and sister went down or you can
[ __ ] play the game dude and i was
like the reason i brought you out here
is this is the game dude this is the
[ __ ] game george and you can do this
man people have such a you have a choice
between the story you were dealt in the
story you can tell yeah and and will the
story that you've been dealt be the one
that you tell for yourself and this is
like such a great think about all the
stories he hears though yes
yeah all this [ __ ] well why is my life
life is a series of choices
and sticking with them and the hardest
thing for people to do is actually make
a choice because they're always thinking
about the future now let's watch stevie
beat the show yeah let's watch it let's
watch it but what i'm so proud of stevie
i pick him up
i can tell by stevie's movement that you
just went for the duck under there yeah
yeah i told you yeah yeah
he's a strong boy but he almost got
steve right there but watch like boom
oh wow
that's when steve almost tore his acl
wow all right you can stop it yeah but
you know i had to do it because i felt
his
his power now you have to do did you
have your [ __ ] butt on a shelf somewhere
cheering you on
yeah it was like clapping
you're a strong strong man
you're a strong strong man boom fully
redeemed yourself
yeah very very tender hands all right
nick let's get to the show shout out to
george yeah we love george yeah george
who's hungry out there maybe you're
watching this podcast right now keen to
see i mean i'm starving i don't feel
like going or i got work to do i gotta
pick up the kids i don't have time to
let my friends at grubhub help you out
man best thing about grubhub grubhub
loves restaurants man they love
restaurants and they want to drop off
the food the way it was intended from
restaurants restaurants work hard to
serve their customers so grubhub works
hard for them for example grubhub works
hard to serve restaurants and that's why
they paired up with panera bread man and
they're doing a little extra with panera
today grubhub's doing a lot for panera
get a free delivery perk on your first
order from panera of 15 or more order
through the grubhub app or online
grubhub we serve restaurants
man how many of you a mayor collins are
sick of the high deductible health
insurance plans it's exhausting man and
then you go and you're on the hook for
thousands of dollars on deductibles
co-pays sky high premiums i'm sick of it
introducing crowd health if you're sick
of it man it isn't health insurance it's
a better way to pay medical expenses man
that's exactly what it is it's flexible
membership as a monthly subscription
start or stop when it's convenient for
you all right they have simple
transparent pricing all right customized
to fit your needs crowdhealth lowers
your monthly healthcare cost all right
and you can see any doctor you want man
it's simple you use their app you find a
doctor in the area ranked from one to
five stars probably go more towards the
five star one
i'd probably stay away from one star
we're talking about health here
membership right they have a committee
of health conscious members who want to
get and stay healthy in return for lower
prices crowdhealth is able to offer
amazing prices because of its community
of health conscious members but for
limited time the kingston listeners and
viewers get their first month free and
after you've been a member crowdhealth
will include a fitness wearable that's
30 days to drive risk free plus a
fitness wearable just go to
joincrowdhealth.com fit enter the code
kats that sign up that's
joincrowdhealth.com
fit promo code kats crowd health is not
health insurance it's community-powered
alternative terms conditions may apply
join crowdhealth.com fit promo code
k-a-t-s it's always weird yeah i go we
haven't started the show yet
all right let's get into the show yeah
i'm glad you guys are loose got to know
each other yeah well we'll start
now what color dildo do you think she
has oh it's multicolored uh turquoise
yep for sure colored unicorn it's just
solid that jason
yeah my name is mandy i'm 20. i live in
rochester new york this is my dog king
and he lives in rochester new york
um
i have a king interesting it for you
guys uh my kenya or stinging it is body
modifications um tattoos and piercings
have become more and more mainstream
over the years um not as controversial
as i have anymore
but i'm talking about where you actually
go out of the way to modify your body
like remove a part um
or you know enhance that i have two inch
ears
i have a piece of my ear cut off
in the jar
no and then i have a throat piercing and
yes that is a real tattoo i have 666 on
my throat gangster so kenya is singing
game buzz but she's not getting a job at
wells fargo let me start yeah can i
start what they need to start showing
because now where it's now 2021 we've
been lived in modern times for a while
now they need to start showing old
ladies yes who've done this stuff with
their ears and let's see how they're
living now because your ears still no
matter what they droop down then you
also have that yeah so they look like
[ __ ] hound dogs
i just want to see like show these
people sit show what the tattoo looks
like when you're now 70. show what the
like your ears look like show what your
nose looks like show like all the things
that you've done and see how how is it
gonna be when you're you know 60 plus
but but have you ever seen a
seven-year-old where you're like damn
that they look dope yeah very rare
there's a couple yeah you look like [ __ ]
no matter what might as well pierce it
up or tattoo your face well then there
you go the other thing i i'm confused
why did she cut off there you go i love
it this is what she was saying for it
her issues are makeup that foundation is
yeah that makeup's jars am i right
am i right you know what i'm glad you
showed that can we see that that's
probably a good example right there that
couple
who's that couple what wow
that's love
that's real love damn that is cool did
she say she cut her ears they look like
victorian lamps you know what that's
actually
that's actually
[Laughter]
i feel like there should be
but what does she mean by like like
people who make themselves look like
lizards and stuff that too but like all
body modifications like the ear thing i
just i mean more power too they've been
doing africa for how [ __ ] long they
put the plates in their lip if that's
what you want to do and it's kind of an
attention thing i think yeah i just
don't find it attractive yeah you know
what it's not sexy you know what i think
there's cool things you do to enhance
your body that would be pretty sexy oh
there's a term as the oldest person
right here
i don't want to be like the crotch the
old guy no but please you know but no
but but i was i was once i when i said
that and they googled that stuff and
they showed the older people i was like
you know what this is fine yeah that's
fine it's fine
and actually that that those body
tattoos or those old people we're
actually distracted about how disgusting
and old they look you know what i mean
you know what i mean it's almost like oh
that's actually dope it's kind of neat
yeah you know so i'm like you know what
more power to you i'm king in it
hard king for me i just don't find the
the
thing i'm confused i don't know why she
cut her ear off
that's an interesting is that a new
thing i wonder what like the gauges they
call it gauging right like that
why would she cut body integrity
identity disorder but did she cut her
ear so it's pointy she had a piece i
don't know maybe
the word disorder makes it not good yeah
well the disorder is the people that
turn into like actual lizards but at
what point does it teeter into disorder
and i'm i'm all for it bring up a lizard
or a girl like they they
i don't like the ear thing i have to
sting that i don't find everything yeah
that's sexy yeah your thing's
interesting but i think that leans more
into like maybe the disorder thing and
i'm all here for living your life living
your truth do your thing but
go to the guy on the far left yeah see
that vampire teeth that's another see
that that's a disorder that that's crazy
i don't know about that i feel like
that's the story that's crazy that
should be accompanied with some really
heavy therapy and i mean that with love
they probably drink blood and you know
what i mean well here's the thing he's
kids but you know if you live people
that live in communes and people that
have like i mean this person's not going
to be like you know you're not going to
not you're not going to swipe right on
tinder but the person that is they
probably be like oh i like this i mean
there's obviously people that like this
i don't get it small i'm not into it
yeah i would never in my life do that
ever but it's like it is what it is so
that's not it that's not makeup that's a
tattoo
yeah he put implants in his hair he they
file their teeth so they're sharp like a
whoa he's not from a commune that's from
middle that's insane that's that's
that's from a different realm yeah i
don't know i'm feeling something like i
feel like why do you see this and you
feel bad for them and i don't know
because you know how to enter because
how does that end
like how does it end for her
i mean i i guess you can work in the
circus of venice
yeah like
there's not gonna be a lot of career
choices there but there's that's why you
feel bad i feel like yeah because even
though it's my own people in an uber
next one doug but i'm saying this this
is our perception of what we think is
normal right like i want to get an uber
with that [ __ ] he wouldn't if his tongue
was like crawl to you yeah he's crawling
there's no uber that guy and he'd be
driving lyft
he's in a lime green [ __ ] scent
that's some shade on lipsticks
she didn't we need to get her vote did
you king or sting it i king it because i
think life is so short go crazy do your
thing but i also think it needs to be
accompanied with some some deep
betterhelp.com psychotherapy yep
betterhelp.com
yep slash griffin actually okay
all right
all right king of this thing
but i have one too all right
oh yeah king of the sting does this like
a cute ari
yes
what's up guys it's eric out here in la
and i've got a debate club topic for you
i don't know if you saw it but over the
weekend nick cage got into a little
trouble in vegas he got kicked out of a
restaurant for being
pretty drunk starting fights with some
of the staff and he was also mistaken
for a homeless person at one point
he's getting a lot of [ __ ] across the
world right now just people people
really making fun of him and i think we
need to you know step back and just
really remember how important nick cage
was to all of us i think that's what his
movies mean um so my debate club topic
for this role is
what is your favorite nic cage movie
mine is conair and his new movie jiu
jitsu thanks guys gang gang buzz buzz
kanye great movie kind of put the bonnie
back in the box what what other movies
do you have face-off was big national
treasure was big
one pig is a great performance by really
i heard nothing happens pig
what's that one you know what happens is
nick cage gets into a realm he's never
really been in which is real acting yeah
well that's not true
leaving las vegas
well he never left las vegas because
look at this this is him in vegas that's
really him but i mean this guy always
under armour sandals on wait guys he's
been in the most movie i've ever i'm not
gonna be surprised i'm not going to be
surprised if in a year a movie comes out
and this is a character yeah he's
practicing he's got two into it yes
leaving las vegas too
so many actors have done that
jim carrey's done that
remember that movie joaquin phoenix made
that was like yeah i'm still here you're
still here like that was sort of a
mockumentary type of thing i wouldn't be
surprised if he's just preparing for a
role that's a good point yeah or he's
just batshit crazy you know what he does
with his money he bought a a real uh he
raises taxes
i don't know if he does he got in a
little bit of trouble oh he didn't get
in a little bit of trouble he bought he
bought like a straight-up medieval like
uh castle and then he put real dinosaur
bones in it and his man his business
manager like dude this t-rex skulls like
70 million dollars he's like buy it and
now he's like that's why he's making
shitty movies no no i because he's
trying to like i think he pays for all
this random [ __ ] but i think he has
serious tax issues and for the last 10
years he was making any movie that he
could just pay it off and just to pay it
off and i think he's probably out of
debt and now he has some money and he's
like doing what he wants to do with it
yeah i think you're right i think it's
probably a character those under armour
sandals would beg to differ as far as
money goes but i feel you oh you know
what you want to live rich you got to
look poor a lot a lot of people live
like that look at warren buffett he's
like one of the richest dudes dude
mcdonald's i know exactly i used to go
to clipper games a lot i was you know
i had like a lot of flex but i had
tickets with adam you know what i mean
we had great seats but the guys that
were sitting in the front row
i mean
red beard
like just looking terrible you know what
that is billionaires yeah yeah
it's smart
but there's also lack of fashion sense
too you know what i'm saying like they
just don't give a [ __ ] no no they're
buying professionals i get that but
here's the thing though yeah when you
look at
the the old white guys that are just
like you go who's this guy they're the
ones with the money yeah you know and
then like you know some rapper come in
with like you know you know just like
all these chains you know like
just look at this
there's a fine line
like you don't need to wear sweats for
the goddamn game you know what i'm
saying
your image you're not worried about
looking rich you're worried about being
rich people who look rich are usually
broke as [ __ ] yeah and
or their wealth won't last because they
don't understand what it takes to retain
for sure yeah i don't know why i yelled
about that
yeah i'm very passionate about finances
because i come from a broke family
yeah you guys keep referring and uh
referring uh
rappers you know and i feel
you know like obviously they're bad with
money but there's a lot of like rich
people that have good fashion sense you
know there's a few things let's name
somebody there's like six on the top of
your head
show the top ten billionaires in the
world and let me see like if they if
they if they floss
steve jobs steve jobs two don't even
wear turtlenecks
i'm dressed like bill gates right now
elon elon
elon you're on justin basic yeah but
leon's basic he's in t-shirts and jeans
he gets tailored [ __ ]
yeah who else customized i don't i'm
just trying
jerry seinfeld t-shirts and shorts jay
seinfeld don't got we we talking about
we talking about look at this what is
this money money yeah who's here we're
talking about wealth this is a fashion
mogul named james goldstein that's a
witch he said every nba game he could
possibly be that looks like the [ __ ]
keeper thing yeah he's tough looking so
this is what indiana jones looks like
that's tiger king three that looks like
something that nick cage bought to put
in his house
nick cage is practicing to play him in a
dubai yeah that's what he's doing
a biotic what else you got nick all
right so to catch jessie may up one time
we did a cat's dating game a girl said
she was looking for love her the guy she
thought she was gonna marry dumped her
so she was like if you guys can find
someone for me we did a little dating
game oh and this girl uh dime piece
she's attractive she's beautiful yeah
couple uh that was a couple months ago
do you think she needs our help
is she a good person and smart um we
have no idea that
that's the problem
and we go she's beautiful instead of
like what does she contribute and is she
educated yeah well we're not playing a
audio of her like doing a dissertation
well you shouldn't be like oh she sounds
smart all we know
is we're showing a picture yeah okay
this is a video she tells us a little
bit yeah i don't need a ted talk from
here
yeah fair enough yeah so we're going to
see her submission and we'll bring her
in look at some guys for her and then
and then help her pick the guy yeah she
so i sent her because last time it was
hard to coordinate the zooms i sent her
the audio of all the submissions and she
already picked three so those guys are
scheduled but we're going to look at the
other ones she uh went to cool that's
awesome
where does she live do we know uh york
pa do you have info on her oh we're
gonna listen okay got it
hi brendan eric bo and stevie my name is
lex i listen to your podcast episode
with kat's dating game and i saw that
the last girl got engaged and i'm hoping
to have that same outcome if you guys
feature me on an episode i'm 25 i'm from
york pa and i like working out at the
gym running in the park playing with my
dog and hanging out with my friends
on the weekends you'll find me working
my job outside on a barn at a winery in
maryland
i somewhat recently just got out of a
two-year-long relationship with a
narcissist and i just have to say i'm
really glad i'm putting myself back out
there good for you the types of guys i'm
looking for are built active outgoing
but also dependable and i also don't
mind talking to you guys outside of my
area i don't see her back from you she
wants a miracle
she's like
i want a really in-shape guy who
it's like she's probably around it all
the time like you're attracted to [ __ ]
boys and that's what you get
you know the problem is sometimes with
people
i can speak from a female perspective is
you swing the
so she dealt with a narcissist yeah and
it probably burned her and sometimes to
compensate you swing all right so she's
looking for a soy boy
but that's not sustainable no you know
because it's not your match can you ask
a question though
since you're giving the female spirit
just a quick question then we i'll even
ask her the same ques the question goes
out it's like like he didn't become a
narcissist oh yeah
well maybe he did
so he was a great guy and then he turned
into a narcissist maybe maybe he was
really like this really attractive guy
like you weren't got to know him
oh
yeah yeah well that's what i'm saying
give him girl
give us the scoop girl
hey we just had some questions about
your your last relationship you said he
was a narcissist yeah when did he become
a narcissist or you just didn't see he
like win the lottery and then became an
[ __ ] i'm sure the last thing you want
is a bunch of men screaming at you about
your failed
relationship me let me filter that for
you first of all hello how are you guys
i'm good how are you i'm good here's the
question here's a question they mean to
ask when did you recognize his
narcissism first
well i feel like i didn't really know
what a narcissist was until towards the
end
until i had a friend describe it to me
and then i was like wow he liked that
so damn
they like the beginning so i was having
all the red flags in front of my face
and i didn't even catch it so does that
mean then there is something about a
narcissist that you were super attracted
to good point
which is my point
no i don't know it's kind of hard um
they're like super manipulative and uh i
don't know i guess they just pick on
weaker people so
was it no no no you know what i have to
step in
you're not weak
no when someone is super manipulative
when someone is like the narcissist like
that you're not weak because you got
taken by that it just means that you're
sensitive and loving and you were open
and you were vulnerable and people like
that take advantage of those type of
people you're not wrong you weren't bad
that guy's just like he just is that way
so don't it's not your fault because
that's you blaming yourself it's not
your fault all right it's not your fault
but don't do that [ __ ] again yeah you
got to armor yourself no you know you
have to also like recognize all i'm
saying is this you have to recognize
what you're attracted to
and take some more time to find out
about the person other than he's
athletic and attractive yep
facts yeah
now was he a successful narcissist a
good question oh you're paying his rent
[Laughter]
no no actually i was living with him and
he was paying rent
okay
um
i guess just more so like
controlling like i didn't really go out
with my friends that much
he's insecure
i got really depressed
it was just bad it sounds more than
narcissism it sounds like there's like
another personality disorder going on i
dealt with that
before i had to get a restraining order
i dealt with the same type of narcissism
and you start questioning yourself like
what what how did i get here like am i
crazy yes you start thinking you're
crazy
and you know now red flags wave and i
was like yeah let me be on this
emotional roller coaster for the rest of
my life but now is the time for you to
like switch it up and be with somebody
else's age is a thing too you're 25 now
you were 22 23 when you met this guy you
were like you know it was just like you
were having fun and i was gonna get that
and now you're looking like you know
what i'm thinking about my future and
what kind of person do i want to be with
and i get that you say hey i want to be
with a person that looks and feels in
this certain way and i want them to be
this this and this you might not get all
that but try to get eighty percent i'm
surprised because obviously you're
attractive girl you know this i'm
surprised you're not getting meeting
guys at the gym there's usually a ton of
people dudes at the gym
you don't want to be one of those guys
i don't want to meet anyone at the gym
because if it's bad then they're ruining
my sanctuary and i don't
yeah what's your ethnicity if you don't
mind me asking you don't [ __ ] where you
live i'm black and white okay
uh should we uh watch some of these
submissions for it for yeah let's see if
we can help you out here i don't think
it's me that tough for you to find a
date but we'll see what happens here
she's not looking for just a date she's
looking for like a woman hey man one
step at a hard time
okay what's up lex i am joaquin i'm 25
years old and i'm seeing
no
we're out
sorry
same state awesome [ __ ] yeah uh real
quick trying to keep this short and
sweet teach cooking classes kids cooking
classes i bounce at a nightclub and i'm
trying to get into mma i got my first
muay thai fight coming up on halloween
so i'm hyped about that uh worked my way
down from 260 to 170 175 disciplines on
the day
height very very important for females i
get it um five nine put me in the right
shoe but get up to about five ten five
eleven it's about to be winner i'm being
boots i get close to six foot yeah so
close
um
yeah he seems nice pretty much
you are absolutely gorgeous i would love
to take you out on a date sometime i
like him he's confident other than that
that's all i got i like gang buzz buzz
buzz buzz
she had a problem she caught him he has
a man bun you shook your why did you
shake your head at the tank top and then
no no you're thinking something you know
what's so hilarious
something right now can i point out
something right now so when we were
looking at her picture and she was all
like well we can't just like you know
she's pretty but what is she how is her
personality
and you know everything about him
you don't like him image is important to
him but look he's dropped like a hundred
pounds so he's disciplined he's just
chilling at his house give him a chance
i'm 50 50 on him
i'm like i'm not sure i'm 50 50. so her
tank top's okay
how tall are you how tall are you
i'm five seven and a half oh [ __ ] dude
five nine worked yeah cute [ __ ] does it
work yeah yeah
no she wears heels when she's at five
two she needs to buy six foot i see it
in her face
would you date a shorter guy no no no
never well i'm asking her never
i mean i'd go on a date with a shorter
guy but i wouldn't marry a shorter guy
no yeah she's not putting an ing at the
end of that journey
she's like let's see what this guy has
got that's a time stamp this guy seems
serious hey this is ricky i actually
just got out of bed to make this video
so it shows that i'm willing to put in
the effort when uh really it's required
okay a little effort indianapolis i'm
working on my transition out of the navy
so i have plenty of time
oh wow like i said i'm down in annapolis
he's being an [ __ ] i said he got
those dsl yeah he does he does though
he's a cute guy
yeah you guys are laughing no dsl is
good have a great day um he seems nice
seems real serious yeah and also if he's
gonna force you to watch jacksonville
jaguar games they're the worst team in
the league and are you a ravens fan
they're gonna be good
um i'm not really any fan i like to
watch football but i mean ravens is
probably the best right now so i guess
yeah
now you were were you feeling his energy
i don't feel a lot of it i'd like to
give him a monster energy drink have him
redo it the way he started the video by
saying he got out of bed just to make it
so there's his
like what is that i know and then but
also that he said he was in the military
which early rise is no no the the
standard
but what i'm saying is the way it came
across is like like it don't feel like
effort you know like he just said you
know i got i rolled out of bed and i
made this he was like girl i'll do
anything for you i got out of the bed
but to his crowd though he thinks
in his mind he thought he did something
good we didn't remember that like his
intention wasn't bad i think he was
trying to be funny yeah yeah i don't
think you should if that's funny dude
i'm not saying it was look how [ __ ]
friendly he looks in that picture right
yeah yeah he does look very friendly in
that picture but so did ted bundy yeah
is he handsome he's traditionally
handsome yeah now is he better now is he
better looking than the first guy
because i don't think so i think so i
like the first guy she try not to like
alert her of the looks she hasn't seen
oh she's she can't see no she's only
she's going oh this is blind danger she
will meet them once we bring him on zoom
but she's doing first of all she's going
to like this guy
you're going to like it straight up
straight i don't think so i don't think
so okay i think you will i will i'm
going with what she said okay i like
this can we do side bets i like the best
yeah i don't think so red flag for me is
right off the bat this guy wants some
like extra credit points for doing the
bare minimum no thank you right exactly
exactly okay
i do think that this is part of his
personal he's military so he's reserved
bye felicia okay and i think listen to
you and i think that he
and i think that he just that's part of
his personality but i really think he
meant well yeah yeah
no way that's a handsome man right there
check this one on fire that's a handsome
man
this one likes already he likes
his relationship he looks short yeah
he looks strong
you know a guy submitting his love
application for lex that tall drink of
water uh a few things about me i am five
seven in heels so you will have to deal
with that uh but it will draw more
attention to us even though you're super
fine so i don't think we'll have that
problem
i work for the biggest podcast in the
world
um so that's pretty cool i do video
forum travel everywhere uh very you know
crazy lifestyle but you could come along
for the ride
i would say i would come pick you up
take you to dinner but my car drives
itself shout out elon musk
and just you know catching a real vibe
with each other it can be nice it's
going to be fun um you know if we hit it
off maybe we'll go to paris rome maybe
burbank maybe even malibu i don't know
we're gonna figure it out um and i think
uh there's gonna be a real spark between
us so uh hopefully you pick me and if
you don't uh you know
it is what it is baby definitely the
best submission video i don't like that
i called her baby yeah he's a goddamn
keeper that guy i love the travel
spectrum i love this freaking
burbank yeah because he really means
paris las vegas the hotel in las vegas
you're gonna want this guy i guarantee
you that he's witty you're gonna want
him he's fun he's fine he's a keeper
he's he looks like the friendliest one
out of the box and he's not contributing
to the co2 emissions in the world
all right
is this the last one uh we got two two
more okay
hey guys this is my submission for lex i
was just about to hit this happy bag for
a minute and i was on instagram and i've
seen uh lex and i got to submit because
she's the real knockout okay um my name
is tyler
tyler perry like medea
hell no i look a lot like him too
apparently you know but i'm 24 years old
i'd be 25 in march i'm a contractor i do
home remodeling
i live in walton kentucky which is like
20 minutes from cincinnati if you're
familiar but i got a very reliable car
and i'm very mobile so i can drive to
maryland no problem
um i love to work out i love to run as
well when i'm not at work which i do
work a lot um you can find me in the gym
or hanging on my family i'm a pretty
chill guy
he's a solid dude solid that's it well i
just saw it
my red flag is that earring
wait what's wrong with the earring man
what's wrong with this it's a lot it's a
lie
i can't even see
really do i look how excited
the only thing about this guy is if he
shaved his beard he'd look eleven i need
to see under the hat
but he's assault he you can tell he's a
solid human being he's a real job this
dude is blue collar girl if that's what
you want he's gonna work hard he's nice
he's probably not gonna cheat on you he
can fix it well i don't know about that
oh cause they're airing no but cheating
isn't like a fiscally
specific thing you look skinny
he's in shape he's skinny he's skinny in
shape he could just be hat cute though
we gotta watch out
out here trying to take legs on the day
the reason i think i'd be a good fit is
i'm fit love to work out snowboard rock
climb go paddle boarding every weekend
does he have an orange jewelry
he's probably never made a video like
this before he's super nervous yeah he's
super nervous we gotta let him talk we
gotta let him come on because that's
like he didn't know how to make it no we
don't
you're being harsh on all these guys no
actually
in her favor like that's what's
happening i am being harsh it's the
first you are and we know boo boo is
still that guy's not
she's not
no i like it she's at a different level
yeah
yeah i'm gonna say it's slim picking sis
how dare you lex why don't you let us
know which guys you picked
you might surprise uh
i'll save
ricky
who was ricky
and i guess that last guy we just talked
to he sounds pretty orange juice what
wow you didn't let me ask you this now
i'm biased but you didn't like the guy
with the man bun and the he was a
fighter
but she heard them though yeah but she
didn't like the body
oh here they are yeah these are guys yes
they're
here no no
can she see them now here we go does she
see the one guy with the exact same nose
as theo
[Laughter]
oh he went out he was missing tyler's
got that white r b vibe yeah yeah
yeah
tyler are you talking about that doom
doom doom daddy
no what's the top guy though uh that's
brandon brandon are you in the military
oh
did you make that video at the
commissary at the at the station
no i was uh so i have two jobs when i'm
out here i was at work at the gym so i
made it like while i was on shift there
oh
he's cute
well where's this other guy why is he
like taking something like this i don't
like how long his name is yeah
yeah hey dude pick a last name unless
there's a meal
unless you're an actor you can't have
three names yeah yeah dude that's what
happens when the parents start hyphenate
names you go down generations it just
continues it's also three last names it
kind of so how do you want to do this
think is she gonna talk to him
i think she can ask him questions and
you guys can all pick uh they know
they're just only going to speak when
spoken to essentially
this is a real competition
sure one question we had uh for tyler we
were wondering if you're just hat cute
he's got a hat on again yeah we gotta
take the hat off tyler yeah are you just
hat cute let's see
here we go we gotta take it off man can
we get a drum roll drum roll
he's cute you know he's a cutie pie all
right we're like adorable yeah yeah god
these are good pigs these are three
handsome men and you all you know i mean
the suit really very handsome that's a
bold move so
yeah if he was in a dark alley though i
don't know who would you want if like a
two robbers it's like you know two
robbers came which was going down some
[ __ ] was going down roderick a thousand
percent top right
really yes yeah i don't know broderick
looks like he's got some more experience
under his belt yeah yeah yeah he's seen
some stuff
yeah but you know
but tyler's the one that hits the bag so
he don't let don't don't uh you know
what i mean
these two on the right hit kill people i
think everybody pick everybody picks
pick someone and ask him a question so
okay okay more about him all right you
do you want to take the time piece
bottom left with the hair
tyler yeah okay um tyler where would you
first take our lovely lady if you were
able to take her someplace
um there's a really there's a really
cool park in cincinnati she says she
likes parks that's where [ __ ] go
missing maybe
maybe there
okay that's kind of nice you know what
let me tell you what i liked about that
answer okay is he listens he did he
heard she liked to park yeah you take it
apart he didn't try to floss like i'm
gonna take her to some nice restaurant
he goes no
i'm gonna take her to what she likes
okay i like that i like that too
you go missing in parks i'm just saying
you got a question eric you want me to
go uh let me go with uh top right guys
that was my guy you know that's the
bottom right no no you know you like
that so that's why i'm picking him up
all right so top right top right
the last relationship she was in the guy
was a narcissist how are you different
uh-oh uh that's brandon uh we were
referring all right
i don't know brandon yeah
all right you brandon uh yeah i'm
definitely not a narcissist like
yeah i just always let the other person
talk i grew up big family and stuff so
you definitely gotta get your word in
but
like everybody chips you down if you're
feeling too high on yourself
his family humbled him he's humble
humble
i'll tell you what
look at them on the left should they
have kids right now look at them i don't
know i know i just think i just
why did your last relationship end
my last relationship ended because
i moved from seattle to annapolis and uh
the long distance didn't work too well
where are you now
i just moved to annapolis maryland just
outside of dcc how close is that to your
kids oh it's close yeah less than an
hour can i can i ask broderick a
question please please roderick if
you're going to be long distance with
our lovely lady how will you maintain
it's only valid
will you have to be long distance
sometimes
with this job no i don't want to be long
distance i don't consider an hour uh
too difficult for the weekend yeah
whereas flying cross country is a little
bit different yeah but i think it's all
about uh communication and help uh
setting expectations so
oh good well i'm sold all right all
right i am too lexi now eliminate one
and then we'll have you
ask the last two a question each and
we'll decide from there so
who who
who's out that boy on the right is fun
[Laughter]
um
i think i'm gonna have to go with
tyler
tyler it's not your fault buddy you're
competing with two goddamn people that
fight for your freedom yeah you know
they're in century mode you should bow
out dogs yeah the brand is in sentry
mode right now he just yeah you're salt
of the earth tyler you really are no
you're a great dude tyler we're gonna
find you
[Applause]
brother good luck at the lowe's parking
lot wherever you're at
man i have a question
um okay who could i ask whatever you
want
which one do you want to ask the guy at
the top right i think you should ask
them both i'm going to ask you guys both
okay
okay what okay what kind of
what kind do you guys are you good do
you guys have good hygiene and
what kind of soap and shampoo
do you and deodorant do you guys use
meanwhile stevie's rock hard boner
think about it just hoping this irish
spring
three i need three answers
soap
shampoo
deodorant go
project you want to go first oh nice sir
i'll yeah i'll help on this grenade um
so i use uh
i don't even know what the trader joe's
generic brand
shampoo and conditioner and then i use
dove men care for uh body wash sure you
know that nice exfoliating charcoal
whatever they use
and it's working
he's bougie as hell i'll tell you that
right now
i gotta impress me man the trainer shows
trader
i use the three in one shampoo
conditioner body wash 9.99 yeah by the
way because he's not using a bar soap
people poop at the bottom and bonds
you need to give the other guy a chance
oh that's right let's hear it okay he
thinks about it he looks like it's like
military grade buddy
no so first question hygiene uh
definitely better than stevie's
uh time stamp that
that's going out of the episode continue
we use uh dr swatch just whichever one
they said
shampoo
i asked my sister because she used to be
a hair stylist so whatever she would go
to like the salon store for that and
she'll just send it to me and i send her
the money smart
well
both hit it out of the park yeah
because that answer was like he was like
listen i i admit i don't know what's
good so he asked his sister yeah what
are women what do women like and then
she was like use this i think lexi
should ask one question yeah yeah yeah
it's her date like they're not dating us
she should get a couple of questions i
think
there's gonna be some go ahead girl fire
away
uh i don't even know uh
oh my gosh
i guess um
brandon uh
what do you usually do in your free time
besides the hiking and climbing and
stuff like what are other things that
you like to do
my days off i usually i always keep an
inflatable paddleboard in my car so i'll
just hit the leg do that for a couple
hours and then
shower up go see a movie grab a bite
sounds like a nice little night does
that sound like a nice little night
yeah that does sound fun
um okay so broderick
uh
what what would someone who doesn't like
you why don't they like you
yeah because you seem picture perfect up
there broderick yeah what's going on
with you someone like me yeah um
why doesn't someone like me
i can be so like
um
i used to work on a submarine and so i
think uh when you're used to like
leading people you can be like pretty
upfront and direct
and so you try too hard you care too
much
i think uh i think some people like
being around the bush when they're
trying to like get to like problems or
whatnot [ __ ] like pretty upfront
yeah and so some people can take that as
like oh he's too aggressive like i did
i've been playing rugby for like 16
years so i'm used to being aggressive
i'm used to that and so um it's just a
matter of just being like having the
courage to be up front with people and
some people don't like that
he's he's straightforward i think i
think she needs to pick yeah
these guys
if i was a chick man both you'd be
flying to l.a right now it just comes
down to the vibe it comes down to the
vibe yeah yeah yeah let's let her pick
nick yeah what do you think lexi go
ahead lexi now there is no wrong
decision well there is
uh um
uh right now i honestly really like
broderick
yeah boy it's fine
yeah
uh-huh
get your guys's info exchanged yeah and
let us know take a lot of pictures i'll
tell you right now i'm liking it and
just seeing you two on the screen right
now
there's a vibe here but brandon i'm
telling you right now the world's your
oyster
was it a tough choice really was it a
tough choice or
it was it was yeah it was it felt like
it was brandon's dm's about to get
flooded yeah
nine the epitome of average i knew it
all right all right that's 510 with
heels thanks guys uh like i said we'll
get you guys connected and that was fun
yeah thank you guys for playing all you
guys are great people yeah name the
first real connection
yeah let's do it brother appreciate you
guys man thanks for your service oh yeah
thanks for your service exactly
give us a look no they don't really do
that actually even if this doesn't work
out i think you'll be all right girl
yeah i think i think you're doing just
fine in life yeah good for you the first
red flag and get past this get that
other guy in your he's in your head
right here i want you to go like this
and just throw him away you have nothing
to do with that that guy is gone and
don't even worry about it don't let any
of that nonsense stay with you it's just
everything
off of you call my boy broderick gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of you how about that
because he'll be very direct submarine
yeah
okay
all right well that's what we do here
appreciate you guys
wow what a success that now that video
[ __ ] him yeah
another guy's here and then that guy
that's a king that's a king right there
king in the yellow shirt it's crazy
that's a real king it's so interesting
just the evolution of people's
personalities like this it's so quick
obviously because it's little videos but
that was first and foremost you couldn't
tell at all you can't tell anything you
can't tell anything at all so you're
going based just off look you know
you know what that's what i'm saying you
know what one for one time uh i remember
when steve harvey show was on he had
this great he had these three women on
all right and yeah and they were gonna
do a dating game there was three guys
and he let them see the guys first then
the girls picked the one that they
wanted and it was all based off looks
and then he
you know hid them away separates our
personality and then then it was like
the guys who each would talk from behind
a curtain i remember yeah every single
time they pick someone different wow
you know it was like and it's like oh
because but that's just we i don't know
how one day
we will evolve past
our sexual desire i don't think we will
because the initial attraction is is you
know physical it's evolutionary it's the
first thing you see i understand but
like it's it's so much like man that
that that thing oh yeah there's more to
it yeah well let's ask her what do you
look for what's first impressions
meeting a man like what what catches
your sturdy what do you mean by that
like the stature like how stand up in a
wind storm i have a better question
okay
you are you're not you don't have to say
your age 39 she okay perfect she's 39.
okay all right so this is the thing
though at 39 you're saying sturdy at 22
what were you saying skinny skinny um
rebellious at 22 i wasn't saying
anything because i was like too drunk to
even like form a sentence really yeah i
was like whatever's there that's
dangerous yeah a lot of plan b i didn't
really have as many standards i think in
your 20s that's the fun of
whatever yeah there's no judgment we're
hanging out there's nothing really
stupid what about late 20s where you're
starting to think about it like she's
starting to think about it but you start
to develop more you know requirements i
think what are some of those
requirements
live it's not happening no i don't i did
that's my homie
i know it's that's the home in a plastic
bag
i'll tell you that much at least my
fuckbot will come in like a like a
velvet yeah
like a like a bowling bag dog
tyler just sent a thank you note i think
she made the wrong choice oh no
he is a catch tyler's both though
thank you they can't be broke and they
have to be going towards something like
a goal a goal no my late 20s when you
start having a minimum standard it's
like he should have a job and that's a
place to stay yeah you know what i mean
yeah but even like in your 30s it gets a
little muddy you know
like our girl lexi you know you you get
you get
you get you get sideswiped by some of
these dudes i'm sure you guys go through
it too women like you know women or can
be just as witchy as as men can be does
the size of the penis matter
anyone tells you matters lying like what
is that
different size what's the ideal penis
size that you're looking for enough i
mean just give me some inches
it's a hard pass
tell me what's happening
dude brendan that's the homie
just tell me when to stop
i can't that pointer finger
starts throwing me for a loop well steve
you're doing it wrong you got to do like
this
like a subway sandwich tell me when to
stop are you ready is it three inches
so where does everybody have shows
yeah
i'll be at the addison improv this
weekend
i'll be at dallas addison improv come on
out and i want to thank all the even
some of the king and the sting fans that
came i was just in boston and people
have come up to me and been like love
you want king
like i love you eric and stephen yeah so
thanks for all those fans that came out
for there but i'll be at addison so come
check go same in dallas everybody and
i'm in denver this weekend hometown
comedy works downtown denver uh thursday
friday saturday and then next week i'm
at the new wise guys in las vegas
california or las vegas nevada jesus
christ uh thursday friday saturday all
right get your tickets at thickboy.com
where does he put you up there
uh i get airbnbs smart yeah go ahead oh
um i have a new podcast called girl gyrl
with my girl carly aquilino love it we
kick off our tour for that in new york
city at the city winery october 9th
and my wide open tour is available and
my podcast sharp tongue i love it
youtube.com slash
scissor bro we missed you last week dude
i missed y'all too yeah
you're the secret today go get your hat
where's my hat
oh i didn't know you guys like our
moments do you hate marketing yeah i'll
bring some i'll i'll rock that hat you
will you should make a [ __ ] butt with
the scissors on it ooh
for women
okay
boom bunch of options all right yeah oh
like a butt what hat butt hat that'd be
fun all right guys denver see you this
week love you guys theo misha see ya
brennan and theo fighter and weight i
gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino burning ain't the queso in
the case of ritos but everything's gonna
be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you driver couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
all right we are outside of thick boys
studios with steve yes we are
today
today is a monumental day uh it's it's a
day of growth
it's a day of
just
moving forward in my life so i'm getting
rid of thelma
today
i spent many of nights with her
and she lived in my closet
and uh as you can can i can't show this
yeah probably not okay so um but anyway
if i i would show you like just to prove
that i did use it a lot because it you
you saw how shredded on it real quick
you just it's a black yeah yeah but you
saw how shredded it was oh yeah yeah
so i i i'm trying to move forward in my
life and uh to make so i could
date real women
uh not like you know it's an object
and because i think this is hindering me
from uh growth
and uh meeting a possible mate
so how about this i just thought of this
i have other
fleshlights and toys that i want to get
rid of
so maybe as as the weeks prolong and
progress i could you know how about i
bring in another tour every week we have
a funeral and by that point all right
later brother but i got a barrel and
burn him by that point so can i throw it
where's the trash can the trash can
right there you're gonna throw it away
here yeah i mean this is the
you're gonna say goodbye to it let's say
goodbye can i i wanna kiss yeah well
let's say a couple words about it i'd
like to say something about it um thank
you for
the time you spent with me um
this is a very hard day
um uh but i wish you the best um but i
can't you i can't live you can't live in
my closet anymore
and i'm trying to grow as a human
that's beautiful
can i say something about it
hold on i still want to do a prayer
thank you